all right do you know how to use this
huh we'll see my name is Philip Anderson
and my daughter is Aris Anderson I am
Andre Harrison and this is Annabella
Harrison I'm Sean Purefoy I mean I'm
gonna do my best
I have some basics now like the ponytail
can't go wrong with that well there's
been a few times like let's say what my
significant other you know was out of
town or you know she leaves earlier than
me in the day and you know I take a look
at heiresses hair she might need some
assistance cuz you know it's curly she
has a lot of it so yes there's been
times where I've had to you know jump in
and put something together confident I
want to see his creativity and how he
could do my hair
really yes okay this is gonna be
interesting
lifetime - in a possible do you like
yeah you don't seem impressed no you
want me to do more than the ponytail
what do you want me to do Elsa will
we'll see about yeah I'm ready
I'm as ready as I'm gonna be I think I'm
as ready as I'm gonna be you're gonna
wear this to school tomorrow and tell
them daddy did it only if it comes out
good okay if it doesn't come out good
tell them I'll do it if you don't like
it um we'll just put it back in a bun
that Mommy put it all right what have
you done Laden duty buddy
well we won't try how was your day today
yeah you have field day today yeah all
right awesome
so what did what events did you do our
field day was it like we talked about
did you just go ahead and throw water
balloons wha
okay did you hit anybody no what's the
perfect achi
and pop oh you got to catch the water
balloon until it pops okay all right if
I if I hurt you
just charge it to the game do you want
to do gymnastics
do I do backflips absolutely not
do you have any homework or yeah yeah no
homework
pack it okay
that's what's up well you know after I
get done doing your hair you know maybe
we can do some reading or not got that
packet no thanks I wanted to go home and
chill out you want to chill out okay
there's one Elsa braid I'm gonna do a
little apart right here let me see your
head straight go from the front down the
middle I don't know how to do that one
I'm gonna do this in the back I'm gonna
do like from side to side straight lines
from like ear to ear how about that it's
gonna be fly watch okay it's cuz mommy
didn't do a good job at making sure
wasn't tingle just so you know nothing
to do with me which is your favorite
song from Elsa I thought it was the let
it go song it is you want to sing it for
daddy
listen you want mommy favorite song
right now use just singing it was
daddy's favorite color no no no I don't
know it's purple yes but what's your
boyfriend's name good I was a trick
question
you better not hand a boy
because yeah you just bet and I had a
boyfriend
we're not doing a boyfriend thing until
how old how old you think you want to be
when you when you want to have a
boyfriend
yes third time's the charm
I'm concerned about my hair as you
should be but again you you you you were
confident that Daddy was going to do a
good job and do I let my daughter down
no do I know all right cool
I don't want to be too presumptuous hmm
all right I don't know if I did your
edges really well I'm sorry but uh I did
my best daddy did his best okay I think
the kitchen is messing everything up on
this thing the kitchen the kitchen is
what they called it back here here why
not like falls out a ponytail you gotta
close the kitchen door well you get the
third grade you'll start hearing stuff
like that yeah we done and time
[Music]
I I tried my best I don't know if my
hands are too big I don't know it's just
I prefer the Clippers but clearly I
can't thank you thank you it's awesome I
think it came all right
it's like bumped up like right here it's
pop in next time you need to use gel -
oh that's what I should have used the
other stuff for the gel - lay down the
head we should have brought gel mm-hmm
oh you think it's good okay is it just
as good as my mommy does it oh okay good
Wow you wear your hair like that to
school Wow okay oh no oh it looks pretty
but your kitchen is out a little bit you
have something at home for me awesome
haha thank you mmm
thank you yeah appreciate it
[Music]
you